dicker dass hier gerade ist eine
prosieben taff berichterstattung
dokumentation über problemkinder den typ
habe ich vor wenigen tagen dem hilft ein
video gesehen zu urteilen wie passt das
denn zusammen das geht überhaupt nicht
herzlich und sowieso wieder hatte ich
mache dieses video hier weil ich auf
youtube ein video gesehen habe wo ich
mir gedacht habe
es ist wirklich so 3 ist gefällt und
dieses video ist eben einen ausschnitt
aus einer fernsehsendung gewesen wo ich
mich wirklich gefragt habe den mann geht
es gerade ernst habe ich es wirklich so
krass ist offensichtlich gefällt das
habe ich immer ein bisschen schockiert
dass wir uns dann schon leute ganz kurz
vorne weg und bei mir läuft heute
einiges leider schief ich war gestern
sehr lange feiern hat einen kater
deswegen sehe ich wahrscheinlich aus wie
müll die birne in der lampe hier oben in
der hintergrundbeleuchtung ist auch
ausgefallen weil heute hat keiner bock
aber ich will ganz klar darum herumreden
leute schauen wir das video rein das
video heißt knast wegen illegalen waffen
problem kids in den karpaten teil 1 taff
prosieben also es geht um die serie
problem geht es in den karpaten das ist
eher die 21 jährige hamburgerin saß
wegen illegalem waffenbesitz ist bereits
in spanien im gefängnis auch in
deutschland kommt sie immer wieder mit
dem gesetz in konflikt
die aviso im kader ist aber auf jeden
fall leute diese sendung ist so dem
prinzip auch die strengsten eltern der
welt und so weiter und so fort
nachempfunden also man zeigt jugendliche
die irgend über die stränge schlagen und
dokumentiert dann wie die übrigen
geschickt werden und daher versuchen
sich zu bessern
das problem bei dieser ganzen sache ist
aber das darf jetzt bei diesem format
ihr einfach eindeutig leute genommen hat
die schauspieler sind ja was man am ende
eben bedeutet dass diese dokumentation
angebliche dokumentationen über dieses
problem geht's einfach komplett von
vorne ein bisschen geschauspielert ist
und es eben nicht hilfen hier ist
irgendwas man weiß das ist einfach fake
ist wo es einfach offensichtlich ist das
fand ich schon ein bisschen krass ok
schauen wir noch mal auf sie ja sie wird
hier als video vorgestellt das ist die
21 jährige hamburgerin saß wegen
illegalem waffenbesitz ist bereits in
spanien im gefängnis okay also das ist
emmi die saß im gefängnis und jetzt
stellen wir auch ein ein problem
ok also die ganzen leute die werden auch
gleich sehen sind so um die 20 ich weiß
nicht wieso die als kids zählen aber auf
jeden fall hat diese emi einfach einmal
bei andreßen mitgemacht okay aber das
ist sie hier
da ist die leila haben wird sich heute
und ich weiß auch nicht genau und wird
eher so als stangen tänzerinnen
dargestellt und liegt mit einem typ
namens htm im bett und gibt den lap
dance und sowas schneewehen ach ja und
bei ab ins kloster hat die auch
mitgemacht wenn ich mir einfach selber
sehen strahle ich einfach weil ich weiß
ich sie einfach gut aus und kein
besseres gefühl ich sitze auf also es
ist so wie gestern wir sind ganz
offensichtlich schauspieler hier aber es
wird im detail dargestellt als sei das
eine echte dokumentation und handschuh
tranter von unternehmer zu werden machte
aber außer punkten gar nicht so kommt
immer erst sehr späte aus dem bett und
das war letztlich der ausweise für mich
dass ich diesen typ mir gesehen habe
irgendwie viel liebe diesen typen drin
gesehen und dachte medica dass hier
gerade ist eine prosieben taff
berichterstattung dokumentation über
problemkinder den typ habe ich vor
wenigen tagen dem hilft ein video
gesehen
zur frage wie passt das denn zusammen
und zwar einem hilft mir video unter
aller wer damit gemacht aber auch in dem
video
mein kumpel knallt meine mutter
prinzessin verliebt
das ist er das ist er hier
[Musik]
tut mir leid ging heute morgen dass ich
einfach so wusste sinn
wieso das ist ja doch oder täusche ich
mich
nein dieses das ist er eindeutig der ort
das ist aber auch gab anfang ist hat die
sehr genau gleich aus was ist das denn
gut runter vom unternehmer zu werden
machte aber außer pumpen gar nicht so
kommt immer erst sehr spät aus dem bett
ist doch komplett sonst eine 1,6
millionen aufrufe auf youtube natürlich
im fernsehen auch wahrscheinlich und
1000 bisschen millionen von leuten
gesehen also wir wissen weil wir den
anderen typen hat leider bei rtl schon
gesehen haben dass das fähig ist aber
die allermeisten leute die den
schauspieler derzeit zufälligerweise
nicht kennen denken sich also das ist
echt finde ich echt schon mega wie etwa
also meiner meinung nach ist das hier
zum beispiel kein kann von den formaten
man sagt er diesen eindeutig so wie hilf
mir das umfeld der drei hat sie nahezu
aufgegeben schon enttäuscht dass das so
dazu kommen musste dass die vorladungen
polizei und knast und dann denken die
sich dabei scheinbar irgendeine story
aus der ist es doch komplett last oder
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen heute das
finde ich schon kritisch noch nicht
ungefährlich also wenn man so
dokumentationen bei dem man als normaler
zuschauer auch denkt ja das sind echte
authentische dokumentation und ich
augenscheinlich erkennbar ist es dass
sie fähig sind wenn man so etwas macht
und dann hat einfach schauspieler
verwendet so finde ich wie er finde ich
nicht so gut
statt nur an sich selbst zu denken und
geht es hier um hilfe für ärmste
menschen erkennen die drei faulen hier
wie verkorkst die eigenes leben ist
wirklich ganz was so monaten
alte stereotype bedienen alte vorurteile
ja die jugendlichen er diesen satz die
sind ja so faul wir eltern die
generationen machen das alles viel
besser
die faulen kinder und einfach nur umso
dieses dieses denkmuster zu bedienen
irgendwelche schauspieler zu engagieren
so habe ich meine es gibt genug leute
die wirklich so drauf sind ist die
strengsten eltern der welt dann auch
komplett gefällt sind die story ist
nicht leicht aber wie soll das alles
geschauspielert
ich halte das heute wieder auch mal ein
bisschen kürzer leute weil sie wirklich
schwer fällt zu sprechen und das
schneiden sie sich ja gleich auch schwer
fällt
ich wollte ich einfach mal dass wir
zeigen schreibt man auch machen dazu in
die kommentare check hier ein für euch
vorgeschlagen das video auf und
abonniert hier oben einen kanal sonst
müsst ihr bald in einer fernsehsendung
mit spielen und so tun als wäre ein
problem teenager obwohl die in
wirklichkeit keiner seite ich bin an der
schule raus leute macht's gut